I used to go every six months and then
every year and then everything was okay
they used to tell me you okay you're not
eligible to be the porter you okay just
don't get in trouble but now is
everything changed
[Music]
for the past four years Minerva Cisneros
Garcia has received the stay of approval
during routine check-ins with
immigration officials but in May her
request was denied Minerva was then told
to buy a one-way bus ticket back to
Mexico if not she'd face arrest and
deportation now the mother of two is
seeking sanctuary inside the
congressional United Church of Christ in
Greensboro North Carolina the reason I'm
here is just to protect myself and my
kids and I just wanna be safe I used to
work and I used to be a mother taking
care of my kids and the normal what's a
mother I own my house I used to work and
pay taxes Congressional United is the
latest ministry providing sanctuary for
undocumented immigrants facing arrest
and deportation
since Trump's victory in November about
400 churches have declared themselves
sanctuaries bringing the total to more
than 800 nationwide what we see
happening is certainly not Christian I
don't really understand how anyone can
justify it from a faith perspective to
tear families apart when we all talk
about Family Values makes no sense to
remove a loving mother who's paid taxes
there's so many myths out there and then
people tend to use their faith or the
Bible to back it up but it just it
couldn't be more clear what we're
supposed to do here in God's eyes no one
is illegal no one is an alien the
Reverend Julie peoples is the senior
pastor at Congressional United Church of
Christ
she's been alarmed at the number of
deportation cases for people with no
criminal record that's why she and the
church stepped in to help Minerva once
Minerva made the decision to come into
sanctuary then we really started kicking
into high gear we arranged furniture
that had already been donated we had
finished putting in a shower that we
didn't have so we wanted to make sure we
had a shower
we started lining up volunteers all the
logistical things that we had learned
goes
- this ice has an internal policy of
avoiding arrests in sensitive locations
which includes places of worship however
those who provide sanctuary to people
facing deportation risk facing up to
five years in prison
Reverend people's is not concerned they
are welcome here as long as they choose
we plan to have them here until Minerva
can tuck her children into their own
beds in their own home now Minerva is
praying for a miracle one that leads her
back to the life she and her sons
enjoyed before this ordeal I miss my
friends from school I wish I can go to
the same school I used to go I would
like to go back to my house and sleep in
my own bed
[Music]